let's go to jerusalem right now and
joining us the prime minister of israel
benjamin netanyahu mr netanyahu good
morning to you morning
good morning great to be with you it's
great to have you as well um
first question after a five-year
investigation the international criminal
courts
looking into whether israel in
particular
israeli soldiers committed war crimes in
targeting civilians
what you know we've seen the headlines
tell us what you can about this story
well i i think this is an outrageous
decision by a
politicized kangaroo court that goes
against the one democracy in the middle
east israel whose soldiers
honorably and scrupulously
do everything to avoid civilian
casualties as they're fighting the worst
terrorists on earth or do everything in
their power
to commit civilian casualties so who do
they put on
investigation israel they don't put on
syria where the assad regime has
butchered over half a million people
or iran that every monday and wednesday
commits
these horrible war crimes this is pure
anti-semitism
this is a perversion of justice this is
something that
happens to us today but tomorrow it'll
happen to you in fact your soldiers are
being
they're thinking about investigating
your soldiers so this is a
an affront to all democracies and
everyone should stand together and one
more thing if i can say i'm in jerusalem
not very far from
the old city of jerusalem which has been
our capital since the time of king david
for 3000 years
they say that if we build a house in
jerusalem
that's a war crime so you know this is
outrageous
exactly that anything that you build
beyond the 67 lines that's a war crime
so this is outrageous this is
particularly outrageous because
the icc the international court was
built to prevent
the kind of horrors that were committed
on the jewish people by the nazis
and now they're turning their guns on
the one and only state
of the jewish people well we're not
going to stand for it and i'm going to
fight this until i'm going to fight this
in every place fight for the truth
fight against his perversion of justice
until this
this horrific decision is
annulled and it will become null and
void we also stand up against it
we've been watching from afar what
you're doing to come back covet and the
numbers
are it's just amazing what you're doing
there 88
of anyone over the age of 50 has already
been vaccinated
vaccinated and then some 75 of those
aged at least 50 year old years old are
already eligible for what you call a
green pass
how are you getting to this point what's
your advice for the rest of the world
how do we do what you're doing
well first of all it's actually 90 of
israelis
of all ages above 16 years have been
uh jabbed at least once and many of them
twice
and the others are recovering so we're
very
how can i say this we're rushing towards
herd immunity
how did we do this quick decisions a
tremendous
distribution system i would say the
mobilization of the citizenry they
understood that
their health and their lives are
dependent on it
uh so we yeah we're very proud of this
you know israel used to be known and is
known
as the startup nation from today it'll
be also known as
the vaccination nation we're setting the
model for the world we're very proud of
it
and we're sharing our experiences with
the us uh with uh
with every other countries in fact i've
got the prime ministers of
denmark and uh in austria the chancellor
of austria
who are coming here today now in about
20 minutes we'll begin
a meeting to share israel's experience
so we can
benefit other nations too as they come
out of kovit well we've got interesting
one of the things that maybe it's a
small point maybe it isn't
but i understand you give people the
option to stand outside a vaccination
center so should they have extra vials
and not necessarily have their name be
called are the category up
you'll go and give them here in new york
inexplicably
they were throwing them out so i wish we
took your lead first on that is that a
small point or a big point
it's it's in israel
you know in america i guess people are
waiting for vaccines and israel vaccines
are waiting for people
uh but yeah we opened up everything
brian anybody can come in
and get vaccinated uh we started with
the elderly but
with the older people but uh you know
we're we're now with everyone and we're
the first country in the world
to emerge from corona with this green
passport you can go to restaurants you
can go to theaters you can go to
movies and sports events i mean this is
this is it we're coming out
look i don't think we're coming out
completely we're going to have to wear
masks for some time
right but we're we're behind it and
we're also looking into the future and
we're saying
let israel become not a world center for
producing the vaccines of tomorrow
so vaccination nation that's where we're
going
that's good mr prime minister since
israel is on the leading edge
and i know you're probably reluctant to
give advice but because so many lives
depend on it
what would you say about what the united
states is doing
and how to fix it or improve it because
different states have different metrics
and are doing
different things
the most important thing two most
important things
is get vaccinated as fast as you can and
wear masks do that you know it's it's
not a political question this is what
has to be done
uh and it should be done by everyone
it's it's your lives
you know i think that we can get over
covert we are getting over covered and
i'm glad to see that
many parts of america are already on
that side and
keep going how did you distribute the
shots because down in florida they're
using grocery stores and other big box
stores to help
but here in new york you have to go to a
place you our convention center the
javits center
start on the app and then yeah and it
takes forever to get through when you
try to sign up apparently online
and they're asking you know the elderly
population to wait five hours at the
javits center
to get their shot and a lot of people
you can't ask someone to do that that's
95 years old
well i was i was actually looking at
doing
exactly what was done in florida and you
know having a lot of
multiple places but we didn't need to do
that because we in israel have a unique
system of four hmos that cover
98 percent of the population with
digital digital
uh databases you know so we're we're
fine so we just
harnessed that and everybody went in but
you know if you're not built for it then
by all means use other elements you know
cut the bureaucracy
cut the bureaucracy jab people save them
and that's it
move on mr prime minister um you went to
school here for a while so you're very
familiar with saturday night live
uh part of the culture uh there is uh
outrage in the american jewish community
in many pockets for this uh weekend
update joke so-called joke by michael
jay
uh there were protests outside of the
taping this week too
about vaccinate vaccinating and how
israel
was only vaccinating a portion of the
population let's listen
israel is reporting that they vaccinated
half of their population
and i'm going to guess it's the jewish
half
that's outrageous that's so outrageous
in fact i brought vaccines and went
especially
to the arab communities the arab
citizens of israel
and the vaccinated as many as we can i
must have gone to
a half a dozen arab communities already
talked with the mayors there
brought the leaders brought the doctors
they're arab doctors this
is just outrageous it's so false and the
interesting thing is
you know not uh accidentally
many many arab citizens are voting for
me because
not only because i brought vaccines for
everyone right because i bought
peace for everyone i brought four
historic peace agreements
that were helped by president trump's
peace team
we brought four historic peace
agreements in in a few weeks
and that everybody in israel said wow
uh you know who brought this and we're
with you so
i have now you know i'm the father of my
oldest boys called the ear
so when i go to arab villages you know
as a term of affection they say
abu yair father of your ear
we love you we're changing history on
that too that's great it's great
uh you know a lot of people in this
country are unfamiliar with
how you reopened your country after the
the lockdown that you achieved for a
while you know
in this country as you know a lot of
school districts are refusing to open to
in-person learning what did you do in
israel
that was effective and safe for
everybody because there are
we just did a story about how uh out in
new jersey
there's going to be a class-action
lawsuit because parents want their kids
in school
they're falling behind otherwise
well i'll tell you what we're doing
first we open the kindergartens in low
grade
you know grades one to four and then one
to six
in most areas we did that and now we're
adding the
additional grade so we're doing this
gradually but i think i think the most
important thing that we're going to do
is add another month in the summer to
help
close the gaps because you know the
intellectual
it's very important to give our kids
both the intellectual and
emotional experience of being with other
kids
being with teachers this is you know
zoom is good
but it ain't that good the the you know
in class learning turns out to be so
valuable and especially important in the
younger ages so that's what we're doing
we're just
gradually building it up and
compensating in summer
mr prime minister i know that you were
close with president trump what's your
relationship
like with president biden he's been in
office for 44 days
well i've known joe biden not for 44
days i've known him for
close to 40 years when i i came in as
the number two in israel's embassy in
1982 and he was
a young senator from delaware so we've
known each other and we've had
a warm relationship over the years i
think
joe biden is a friend of israel i know
he is i know he's committed to israel
but i also know that on sometimes with
the best of friends
in the family as we say we can have
differences of opinion
uh the most important thing that i i i
think joe biden understands is that
my commitment to prevent iran from
getting nuclear weapons
is absolute and i hope that we see eye
to eye and everything but
one thing i believe he understands and
respects is that as the prime minister
of the one and only jewish state we're
not going to let
a bunch of ayatollahs wipe us out from
the face of
the earth or from the map of history so
i will do
everything in my power to prevent iran
from getting nuclear weapons
and so far we've been successful yeah i
i hear you loud and clear and hopefully
the administration does
uh whether they go into the agreement or
not mr prime minister thanks so much for
your time best of luck in the
re-election
i know you're working hard already thank
you and uh
good luck america thank you god bless
you we need it